Hallo zusammen! Dieses Video werdet ihr euch mit Sicherheit in Zukunft immer und immer wieder angucken
denn heute habe ich die leckerste helle Pasta-Soße für euch!
Die geht sehr, sehr einfach und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach Schritt für Schritt wie sie funktioniert
und dann könnt ihr in der Infobox - also unter dem Titel euch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben einmal ansehen.
Und ich fange direkt an, ich hab hier meinen Herd - meinen Herd auf der Pfanne!
[Hamza] Meine Pfanne auf der Herd!
[Kiki] Meine Pfanne auf dem Herd!
[Hamza] Ich hab gesagt: "Meine Pfanne auf der Herd!"
Wir sind hungrig, ja!
Ich hab jetzt hier schon den Herd eingeschaltet, Stufe 6 von 9
da gebe ich jetzt mein Öl dazu.
Das hier ist jetzt erst mal ein neutrales Öl, da habe ich einfach Sonnenblumenöl genommen.
Und ich habe außerdem schon Hähnchenbrust in so feine mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten.
Das lasse ich jetzt da ganz kurz von beiden Seiten drin anbraten, wirklich nur ganz kurz!
So ungefähr 45 Sekunden von jeder Seite.
Das salze ich und pfeffer ich auch schon und dann kommt's auch schon wieder raus.
So, jetzt hab ich die Hitze ein bisschen runtergeschaltet, denn jetzt geben wir Butter mit dazu und ihr wisst ja, dass Butter immer sehr schnell verbrennen kann oder anbrennen kann
und daher müsst ihr da wirklich vorsichtig sein.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Knoblauchzehe dazu.. hups!
Direkt reingepresst, ihr könntet die natürlich auch hacken.
Und den Knoblauch lasse ich jetzt auch nur so ½min darin andünsten und danach gebe ich in einem Schwung das Mehl mit dazu
und lasse eine Mehlschwitze entstehen.
Das Mehl habe ich jetzt ungefähr 60-90sek anschwitzen lassen, dabei immer wieder schön rühren.
Und es ist wichtig, dass das Ganze so ein bisschen - Ich nenne es immer "atmen", das sieht für mich immer aus wie atmen! -
dass das hier sich so ein bisschen bewegt.
Und da gebe ich jetzt Milch mit rein in einem dünnen Strahl und dann schön immer weiterrühren.
Und sobald die Milch klümpchenfrei verrührt wurde, könnt ihr schon salzen und pfeffern und natürlich auch Käse mit dazu geben.
Kleiner Tipp von mir: Salz ganz zum Schluss mit dazugeben
denn je nachdem, welchen Käse ihr verwendet, ist der schon sehr, sehr salzig.
Jetzt wird die Soße noch gewürzt und zwar mit Oregano und Basilikum.
Und anschließend kommen auch schon die Hähnchenstreifen wieder zurück, die lasse ich jetzt wirklich nur noch 4min ungefähr ziehen.
Sie sind sogar schon gar, denn je kleiner sie sind, umso weniger brauchen sie in der Pfanne um gar zu werden.
Und oft macht man den Fehler, dass man Hähnchen wirklich zu lange brät aus "Angst" sie werden nicht durch
und genaus das macht es dann zäh.
So! Und jetzt habe ich auch schon nebenbei Nudeln gegart, die gebe ich jetzt mit dazu.
Ihr dürft auch wenn ihr mögt ein bisschen was vom Nudelwasser rüber schwappen lassen wenn ihr die Soße nicht ganz so dick-cremig möchtet,
ich finde aber gerade das so lecker!
Und das war's schon mit unserem 15min Rezept, was ihr immer und immer und immer wieder nachmachen werdet,
da bin ich mir 100%-ig sicher!
Und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen: Ich übergebe gleich das Wort an... Hamza!
Der macht nämlich den Taste Test für euch.
Ich verabschiede mich an der Stelle und freue mich, wenn ihr meinen Kanal natürlich kostenlos abonniert,
mir ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst für dieses Video,
und mir in die Kommentare schreibt, welches Nudelrezept ich als nächstes machen soll.
Und ja, dann würde ich mal sagen: Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Kiki] Warum bist du so eingepackt?
[Hamza] Mir ist kalt weil du mir keine Liebe zeigst!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] So Leute! Es ist heute Valentinstag und ich bekomme keine Liebe von Kiki, deswegen..
[Hamza] Spaß! Die Liebe hast du hier mit dem Nudelgericht bewiesen!
[Hamza] Also, wie nennt sich das Ganze?
[Kiki] Eine Sekunde, ich muss zurückzoomen!
[Kiki] Okay, let's go!
[Hamza] Ich hab mich extra nicht bewegt damit das so gleich aussieht!
[Hamza] Wie nennt sich das Ganze jetzt?
[Kiki] Ganz ehrlich: Ich nenne das einfach mal die leckerste Pasta-Soße der Welt!
[Hamza] M-hm, M-hm!
[Kiki] Hamza, wie schmeckt's dir?
[Kiki] Du hörst gar nicht auf, zu essen!
[Hamza] Ich wollte ein bisschen mehr probieren!
[Hamza] Ist das diese Käsesoße?
[Kiki] Käse-Sahnesoße?
[Kiki] Nein, da ist ja keine Sahne drin!
[Hamza] Ist das keine Käse-Sahnesoße?
[Kiki] Das ist keine Käse-Sahnesoße weil da ist ja keine Sahne drin!
[Kiki] Also ist ein bisschen leichter gestaltet wenn man das so sagen darf!
[Hamza] Ich finde das schmeckt schon sehr nach Käse-Sahnesoße dafür, dass da keine Sahne drin ist.
[Hamza] Find ich lecker!
[Kiki] Da ist Milch drin!
[Hamza] Wenn du im Restaurant sowas bekommen würdest (also im Edelrestaurant!), dann würdest du sagen:
[Hamza] "Ey, die 20€ haben sich gelohnt für die Nudeln!" Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich! So schmeckt das!
[Hamza] Ich find's lecker und das Hähnchen ist auch richtig zart! Ich find's super!
[Hamza] Also Leute! Ich find's - oder Kiki - ich find's sehr lecker.
[Hamza] Ich find das hat 'ne klare Richtung von der Konsistenz bis hin zu den Zutaten.
[Hamza] Es ist auf jeden Fall lecker. Also Knobi ist auch richtig gut - nicht zu viel, nicht zu wenig!
[Hamza] Ich glaube, das passt auch zu anderen Nudelsorten ganz cool.
[Hamza] Ich glaube, man könnte sogar noch Brokkoli reintun!
[Kiki] Ja! Gemüse, anderes Fleisch...
[Hamza] Brokkoli.. oder Möhren kann man auch ganz gut dazu reintun, genau!
[Hamza] Macht das nach Leute! Ich find das ist ein echter Allrounder, auf jeden Fall! Ich find das passt zu allem.
[Hamza] Macht's auf jeden Fall nach Leute! Sehr einfach, sehr schnell, sehr lecker! Und.. Abschluss?
[Hamza] So Leute! Das war's dann, ne?
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Hamza] Wir kommen zum Abschluss und ich würd mal sagen: Peace and out!
[Kiki] Peace and out!
*beide lachen*
[Hamza] So, wir lassen's uns schmecken! Lecker, lecker!